Douglas Murray is an author a journalist
an atheist a neoconservative and an
outspoken defender of free speech
Douglas now that I've labeled you all
sorts of things welcome to the show I
told you right before we started that
you know we've only been doing the show
for about two months now but I you by
far I have had more requests to have you
on than pretty much anyone else because
you seem you seem to be like this sort
of hub of free speech and free thought
and that even though I think maybe we
don't line up exactly politically people
wanted to see us sit down so I'm excited
that you took a little time here I look
forward to airing our differences all
right so all right so first what I want
to start with is the word
neoconservative because it's really the
first thing that if someone Google's you
that pops up that you are a
neoconservative or a neocon now I know
since I come from the left this is a
real buzzword for my people they they
freaked out on this think that you're
some sort of imperialist this kind of
thing so first I thought let's just get
what the definition of neoconservative
ISM is from you first
well it's quite nice to know that's the
first thing that comes up on Google with
my name I expected far words neo-cons
knew preserve his work were basically
people who moved from the left in the
post-war period in America and famously
described themselves thanks for having
crystal as being liberal to be mugged by
reality the truth is that now I got a I
wrote a book on neo-cons about ten years
ago now and the truth is is that the
word neoconservatism is so filled with
pejorative connotations everyone thinks
they know what they mean by it like I
wrote a book partly to correct those
misapprehensions I don't think it was
remotely successful in that regard but
I'm I'm not that bothered about the term
I think it's it is interesting and it
remains interesting the movement of
people from a liberal position as it
were but apart from that I think he's
got read a little
relevance today I think that the word is
is probably noxious for at least a
generation right so I think within an
American context
it basically means using military force
to spread democracy is that is that fair
to say no I mean actually mainly
neoconservative America were not
interested in foreign policy the first
the first certainly glut weren't but
it's only in recent years it's been
perceived that I wouldn't said in terms
of bringing democracy I think that I was
striking neoconservative foreign policy
idea was really that idea that you could
use military force for humanitarian
means it partly solved this sort of
imbroglio that had occurred for a long
time by that point which was that people
on the Left broadly speaking didn't
believe in the use of force and people
on the right broadly speaking didn't
think that humanitarian catastrophes
were the sort of thing you used the
military for neoconservatives were few
people to sort of meld these things ago
and say actually as in the Balkans the
use of military force to alleviate human
suffering and to prevent in that case
even worse genocide than occurred was a
good thing however I mean as we all know
the last ten years if if it's possible
for a neoconservative to be a liberal
who's been mugged by reality then I
think it's probably possible now to be a
neoconservative who's being mugged by
reality as well right so I guess this is
why labels just suck in general because
I think what you're saying is there's
there's various lines through here that
you could be someone that does believe
in nation-building and obviously there
are some people that do believe in
nation-building and then you could be
someone that just purely believes on
intervening on hue merit and
humanitarian regards and probably
several other things beneath that right
absolutely but I think that thing of
there being a sort of coalition of
people from left and right you certainly
met I think in the 90s over the Balkans
met again in a bit in the early part of
the last decade
but I think since that alliance that
occurred hasn't certainly gone its own
different ways okay so that's I just
wanted to start there just so that
people have a little bit of a sense of
the word and don't get too hung up on it
before all the commenters start yelling
at you
the gate so I wanted to start also with
that where I became familiar with you
was right after the Charlie Hebdo
attacks in France because you you were
all over the the media and I saw an
interview it was a discussion on al
Jazeera and you were incredibly I
thought lucid and clear and clean in
your explanation of why we can have no
we can have no give when it comes to
free speech so I thought you could
possibly explain that for me now I'm
yeah that wasn't the warmest interview
I've ever had zero what I think you know
one always tries to be polite of course
but it was a bit much that within 24
hours of the 12 people being shot dead
in Paris that al Jazeera invited me on
and wanted to have a discussion about
what this would mean about the allegedly
nascent European hatred of Islam and
Muslims and and so on the so-called
backlash thing and I was fairly furious
about that because I thought that this
was obviously diverting attention from
actual dead bodies on to potentially you
know hurt opinions hurt feelings and so
on and anyhow I did actually it was a
pre record for its worth and I went back
afterwards and said to a colleague well
they're never gonna wear that because
I'm I think I did at some point give the
interviewer who was sitting in Doha
piece of my mind about the fact that he
seemed to well he didn't like it let's
say that when I pointed out he lived in
an unfree country and was working for
non free media and that I wasn't
answerable to him I still haven't if she
got the fee for that interview yeah I'm
guessing the check is not coming in the
mail so I would just let that be so what
I liked about that though is that you
clearly so yeah you called out the the
interviewer in Doha but really you were
you were really calling out your own
media right you were calling up people
in the UK and you were calling out
people in France and probably in America
and all over least that's sort of we
were doing this to ourselves
really before the bodies had been buried
yes well you know it's it's worth
recognizing in a way when you've lost
and we've lost every round of the
free-speech wars in recent years from
the Satanic Verses affair onwards we
always sort of get a technical there's
always a technical way out we allow
ourselves you know I mean after the
Satanic Verses you know thank goodness
Salman Rushdie remained alive but but
basically everybody has been as has been
often said internalized the fact while
there's never been another book like The
Satanic Verses published there probably
won't be in our lifetimes after Charlie
Hebdo you know people walk through the
streets of Paris world leaders in that
sort of preposterous parade through
Paris and Parisians holding up pencils
as if this was an act of defiance no an
act of defiance would have been if
everyone had marched through Paris
holding a cartoon of Mohammed the act of
defiance on the part of the media that
was so desperately trying to find a way
to be showing alliance with their
slaughtered colleagues the best the
media could do was to sort of repeat the
same Weasley excuses they've been doing
for ten years since the Danish cartoons
affair and try to save their dignity I
mean it's a very undignified sight I
think the media after all got remember
it probably Awards itself more Awards
than anyone else in the world
I know firemen and policemen don't don't
don't have endless award ceremonies for
their bravery and give each other metals
and so on but journalists are doing it
all the time there is lots of
journalistic bravery don't get me wrong
but the reason why we keep on failing in
this is because actually our media as a
whole and most individuals just don't
want to make the kind of stand which if
we made it twenty years ago we wouldn't
have to keep on going through today
right and I suppose that's why people
are responding to you the way they're
responding to you and responding to what
we're doing because it seems it seems
late at this point by us talking about
free speech it seems so late and overdue
and I think that's why there's been this
this sort of groundswell of support for
what we're doing do you agree with that
I hope so I mean you know I'm
I'll do it pessimistic there about the
you know the possibility of another
Satanic Verses but yeah look I mean
things could change but it certainly
seems to me that a lot of people are
increasingly aware of the fact that we
live in an age of extraordinary
cowardice at an age of cowardice that
masquerades as an era of truth-telling
you know I mean but these things are
very confusing I think for most people
when they're living through them you
know who if if you just said if you just
said I don't know in 1999 if I'd have
seen you you'd see me and one of us had
said to the other you know the 21st
century is going to be wracked across
the Western world with blasphemy wars
right you just thought you must be drunk
or the most if you believe that
prediction you would have said well how
did the Spanish Inquisition come back
into Europe yeah how did that occur how
did I know out of the Catholic Church
remain returned to medieval times and
start burning heretics well no one would
have thought that in 2015
newspaper offices across the world would
be debating whether they could show a
little cartoonist some guy just just
just not even at the parami not even
them as it were accurate photo fit of
Mohammed yes anything which they then
say could be called Mohammed you
wouldn't have believed that this would
be the thing that broke the Western
press but it is yes so was was one of
the most infuriating parts for you that
actually what Charlie Hebdo did was
incredible satire making fun of all
religions so I saw in that al-jazeera
piece and in another piece where people
were saying that this was racism what
they were doing was racist but actually
it was the reverse of races and they
were fighting for the principles that
the left is supposed to believe in right
well let's not forget the fact that we
live in an age when everyone not only
has an opinion but is expected to have
an opinion and most people therefore
have to mug up very fast on things they
know nothing about
so after Charlie Hebdo in January a lot
of people were just cropping up on
things who had always certainly never
actually seen a copy of
I've never actually read it or seen the
cartoons or knew anything very much
about it but one of the immediate
attacks on the dead journalists was of
course to say they're racist that was
probably for me the thing which fired me
up to keep going during that period I
thought it was and remain under the
belief that it was intolerable that a
group of people could go through the
front doors of the newspaper office in
Europe and gun people down with
Kalashnikovs and then for their fellow
travelers as it were mop up afterwards
by saying well they were kind of racist
anyway I don't know much about them till
24 hours ago but I'll say they're racist
and then nobody needs to mind I thought
there was a real low point